which is the last item on on there on
item nine
we've done the other eight items
executive decisions were made
and sir tim did reflect that he was
really pleased that he's not the only
one that has trouble with new technology
so working our way through the agenda
we've got the minutes from the previous
meeting
which is there for you to digest any
issues arising from those
there being none would somebody like to
move that they're accepted
graham thank you
signed by bruce all those in favor say
aye all right
thank you for your support
moving on to the project update and
there's a paper there
would you like to speak speak to that
jane
yes thank you nobody i'll just speak
briefly you can see that the key thing
on the agenda is the suggested approach
to the legacy report
um
and we are also going to have a verbal
update about the
supporting the mayor group
i don't know whether you want to stop
and have that
now or i can just uh
keep going on a very brief summary and
then we can work through it well it
might be helpful for you for you to
cover that issue of the uh of the two
reports the and the legacy book because
i know you and bruce and claire and
others have had some background
discussions about where that would go
yes and um
in terms of the
legacy report i think i'm going to hand
over to bruce to give an update on where
we've got to given we've had the
conversations as part of the qualitative
review
and
the um
[Music]
online review i think michael would will
tell you how many people
have
responded to that
and the question
that was raised in our minds was whether
we've actually got two reports
one on the
six-month wrap-up
review and one on the
legacy report that's what we have
indicated to date but perhaps of
i hand over to bruce
because he led the discussions with
councillors
and he gives you an update of where we
think so
a sensible path forward with regard to
concluding these things
thank you jane yeah thinks that jane in
fact as you speak it just makes me
realize that we're calling this a rack
up report but it's also a six-month
review the reality of it is having
caught up with all all council and
snobby i'm glad to say other than i
think peter who's been in disposed
it's it's fair to say that
what we have is the information that you
need for the legacy report in fact when
when dan and i sat down to um
collect the information that we've
received from everybody we actually
start we're starting to write the legacy
report so
i have suggested
tanabe as chair of the pgg that in fact
we amend our approach and that we roll
the wrap-up report and the legacy port
report into one
because if you recall the nature of the
questions that you've gone through with
me which was the four issues or the four
presenting issues when we started this
process
uh the talk around the charter
communications and indeed learnings from
the whole actually really the whole
process not just the last six months
we in fact we we in effect have the
material
for the legacy report so it seems crazy
to produce a wrap-up report one month
produce a legacy report the next month
and i think and i would want to
recommend to the committee that you
accept that jane and i just go straight
into a legacy report navi i'd like to
suggest that we do that though
still to the may deadline
okay so not to bring the legacy report
forward
what i thought would be useful is
it would be good to have a workshop and
i'm suggesting either in place of or in
conjunction with the april meeting of
the pgg
um to take
counsellors through
their findings
okay i mean we have a lot we have a lot
actually
a lot of really good stuff that has been
expressed and i think it would be useful
if we could uh find some time doesn't
have to be that day if you wanted
earlier i'd be happy to make it earlier
as well but i'm just suggesting that
to workshop as we have in the past what
those findings are so that i can get
uh in a workshop situation your
views and advice about where that's
going and i can we can share where we
think we're going with a legacy report i
just think it helps with the delivery
because the the intention is and richard
i know you're there and we've talked
about this the legacy report would form
the basis of
uh a letter to to richard suggesting
that we've met the the department's uh
um
overall objectives of of the total
project
so before i open that up just just a
quick reflection um at the
chairs group as well we had some
discussion yesterday just brief
discussion about where this this
committee or group would go
um it was my view that i think the
sooner we move past some of these
milestones the better
it's all very hard to have support from
external people like yourself and the
two eas and the dia
but we are coming up to what i believe
is four critical points
uh the first one is we've got annual
rates to be considered we're
workshopping that and that will be
contentious we have the future of the
museum project which is another area
that will have some
debate internally as well as some
consultation externally we have the
annual plan
and then we get into the silly season
just before the election
and i think if ever we want to show as a
group of counselors that we can act
professionally
now is the time to sort of take away the
scaffolding as it were
and see whether we fall over or not i
don't believe we will
quite confident about that
because yesterday we had some tense
issues up on the agenda around the
museum
but we didn't get any bloodletting or
name calling and we just worked through
a process
and so
for me that was a time frame that we
need to get to that space april may
would be fine by me as you suggested um
the sooner we get the feedback from your
area i think that would be helpful
because people are quite excited about
to know what's what's come out of those
interviews yeah um and i'd be interested
to hear from michael how many applied or
how many
took the time to fill in the
quantitative survey
which is actually a good point sorry
that i i forgot i didn't mention
michael's work but it would be logical
that the the survey work also be sheeted
into the
[Music]
because i think there are different
questions and different approaches and
those too
certainly yes absolutely yeah that's
that was always intended
you might be able to help us michael
just on how many people
yeah certainly mr chair so they were as
of midday yesterday six of the 13 had
completed the survey
well for for the record that that's
an outrageous result to be quite honest
i mean we've put a whole lot of effort
and a whole lot of rate paying money
into getting this right
and for less than half the elected
members to responders
yes it just staggers me really quite
awesome um mr chair there might be an
opportunity if you as chair of pgg
were to email your colleagues today
the survey is still open
and perhaps you could encourage them to
complete it with a view to its findings
being included in bruce's
uh
wrap-up and legacy
so michael the deadline for the
i believe it's this friday but i can um
confirm that i could see jane wanting to
say something yeah i'll come back to
jane in just a minute please um
if you could help me with an email just
to let me know the deadline and who
hasn't done it i want it so i can
specifically target the people i don't
know that i can do that but i will touch
base with our provider and see what
information they can give me yep thank
you for that i'll send you the email
clear
yeah jane
i'd look just to say that if we have to
leave it open for another couple of days
we will because it's vital we get
everybody's input and last time we had
to do a bit of cajoling towards the end
as well
so we'll keep on the case to make sure
everybody has the opportunity
to respond
it's very much goes in tandem with the
other survey so we need these responses
just as much as the other ones yeah yeah
i've been generous jane and your support
there i mean leslie reflected recently
and i did too it didn't take long to do
that quantitative survey
and i did prompt it with people to
encourage them to do it but you know
i'll do another email
today um could i could i just jump in
there for a second um sorry nobby just
i'm speaking to jane's point i'd be a
little disappointed if we had to extend
the time of the survey i think an email
from you is going to be really
really useful but to extend the time of
the survey is to support
poor behaviour on the part of the
councillors and
that's that's just you know here we are
trying to say that council has turned a
corner and yet they can't
do a survey in time
so that would be a last resort i i agree
we need to hear it from everybody but i
don't think we should extend the survey
especially if it's open till friday it's
heaps of time yep
and thanks for that and i fully agree
you can gather by my comments how
frustrated i am um and you're right if
we don't take the
don't take the time to do it it's a
pretty poor reflection
mr chairman i think we should look at
the reason
if we can as to why
it's such a poor turnout
and
i'd suggest that
it's such loaded questions you can
literally guess what the outcome's going
to be
and
i think
it should
be prepared to look at
why
this is such a poor now okay so
um just a response that you worship um
have you done the survey
yes yeah excellent
i've done it too and um but the the
survey is kept in such a way that you've
got a wide range of
responses from
strongly disagree to strongly agree in
the three or four in between there so
they make statements um and you either
agree we don't agree
i i found some of the questions
difficult
to assess and there were three or four
and i raised before the survey that i
felt uncomfortable about some of those
questions
but we did discuss at the time that we
looked to this quantitative survey again
that we wanted to keep the survey fairly
relevant to the previous one so that
we're comparing apples with apples and
not changing the survey because that
could be construed as you're changing
the question to suit the outcome
so
yeah
and again some of the questions i would
have preferred not to answer
um but for more than half the elected
members not to respond
um given the email i sent out
encouraging her without having the
courtesy of coming back and saying why
they weren't doing it
it's a little bit difficult i think and
richard's response from the dia
is a clear stare for us
that's uh not a very positive picture
going forward
cheer if i can just come in there with a
comment yes certainly i
i would object strongly to a description
of the questions as a loaded survey
it's a very ordinary
survey that as you said gives you the
chance to have a range of agreement to a
range of questions that we've
deliberately left as
very similar to the original so
i i think too for anybody to describe it
as a loaded survey is is nonsense
um
it's it's a fair survey it's a serious
survey because we're we've been in a
serious situation i think the
responsible
the responsible um
thing to do was to keep it very similar
because obviously you're going to gauge
the difference between the original and
and the now
answers
but but i do strongly object to anyone
describing it as loaded that connotation
is not um
a responsible way of describing
any of the process we're going through
exactly and and my perspective on that
is i've been in the government sector
for quite
a few decades as you know and we've had
these before and i although i found some
of the questions confronting and would
have preferred not to answer them i
didn't think it was the right way to go
um
by far the best surveys are the ones
that give you a hard hitting statement
and then you either agree or disagree
and you have some mandate in between
and not to belittle what we had in the
communication survey
yesterday lisa so don't don't take
offense to this
but when you do things in a more
subjective way
and the wording's not clear people start
to interpret what does that actually
mean that the questions that were in
that survey were quite blunt
and quite confronting in some cases and
you either agree we didn't agree or you
got into the middle ground
um so and and they did allow some
comments as well
so
certainly i wonder if i did the same
survey because i found it
straightforward yeah i mean
you even agreed to as you said there was
a rain there was a range of
responses and if you're open and honest
about what and you were doing it in your
own privacy as a confidential survey i
thought it was straightforward yeah
i think my comments were more about some
of the questions i thought were a little
bit difficult and i think when we
initially discussed it there were about
four or five questions that an ideal
world may have been taken out
but as you say we want to compare apples
with airport
and see the progress i wouldn't want to
uh navi conflate quantitative and
qualitative surveying which is not my
expertise um but as we've said you know
assuming that we've got a good we should
have a property now
for michael's good work around this
survey we do also have the qualitative
statements and one of the things that
jane and i
um are looking at and are keen to do is
to make certain that the report reflects
your comments
about
the about the results not jane's in mind
there will be analysis from jane and i
yep in terms of in terms of that legacy
report but first and foremost it's to
report
how council are feeling so i think tim
if there are there are issues
uh this that you know you have hinted at
quite frankly i think all councillors
took the opportunity let alone have had
the opportunity to
uh get that free flow and get their view
across for which jane and i will do our
best to try and reflect all sudden
reports so we'll have both side by side
which should be helpful well i think
that was really helpful that we had the
the two parallel processes yeah because
it allowed
certainly in an interview i had allowed
me to explore a few things i wouldn't
have been able to explore in the in the
quantitative cell so that just gives a
bit of meat to the bone as it were
okay jane back to you again with your
aura
right well
do you want to while we're talking about
the um wave four with the legacy report
have a look at
the appendix which is on page
let me just get to it
um
page 20.
now that is just a
literally uh
well it's there's a lot of thought gone
into it but it's a starter pertain on
the
framework and shape of the legacy report
so that we all know
what we're talking about
and it's it's reasonably um
straightforward to read it i think one
of the
things that we noted in putting this
together is that there are going to be
different audiences for this report
it will of course be
counsel itself in the community
the other
audiences we've talked about dia
and where they fit in
there's the sector the local government
sector because there'll be learnings
from this
and also given the timing and you've
said it yourself nobody we're coming up
to an election so the it will be
reflective of how the council is feeling
and be a useful
tool
for potential candidates so we should be
bearing these things in mind
um
section two
scene setting
section three really what we did and
when so that's reasonably
straightforward
um
section four costs and risks
are going to be an important
component of it
you'll notice in there
we've asked ourselves the questions
could we have done something differently
so we'll be open about
that then there's a section there final
review and results
that's what we've just been talking
about
um you in the narrative of the project
report we did see this might change a
bit as we get into writing so i'll just
make that point
and then at the end
what are the learnings
that's so happy to take any other
suggestions comments um
and i think as we're looking like coming
back to having a workshop to look at
this once we've got a draft
to look at i think thanks that um just
one comment that i'd make which is in
year six and six for you and bruce is is
where the part of our learning is
do we have flaws in the system which is
not
not the invercargill system but in the
local government system about how we
control and deal with elected members
behaviour
and i'll on a personal level had some
time with the
some of the panel members on the local
government
future local government review
and raise the issue that
the current procedure is to use codes of
conduct
um and tim and i will probably be on the
same page to say
that they can be nothing more than a bus
ticket to quote his worship on one other
occasion
so there needs to be some learning i
guess or some thoughts going forward to
the wider sector and maybe to central
government about
how how do you not
unmind democracy and freedom of speech
but at the same time have some
mechanisms to control what what is
behaviour that goes beyond those
boundaries
and so i just sort of flagged that i get
and and we're in an ideal position to
maybe comment on that
because we've had ongoing issues in that
area
open it up for a discussion from anybody
else that might want to comment on that
um project update report time frame
perhaps i could uh jump in there nobby
look i think that's
your observations around the future for
local government um
uh work program uh really insightful and
um jane i think you should add the
future for local government and as one
of your um
as one of your
[Music]
groups for the purpose of this it does
raise an interesting question and as i
was reflecting on this earlier i was
thinking about um you know what are the
learnings and one of the challenges is
that
the learnings we've got to be careful
the learnings don't take away from the
um sort of that they'll become they can
become quite objective but i think there
are some key questions that uh the
council is in a unique position to
contemplate through this report what
i've noted is
a couple here what are the indications
of a serious problem within a council
how do you identify those issues early
and what options should be considered
and this goes to your question about
could we have taken an alternative
approach now what tools are available
and i think those learnings are going to
be really important um particularly
around the future for local governments
work the codes of conduct work that is
going on that the local government
commission has undertaken
and has now been considered in the
future for local government space
one of the things i've always said is
that you know one of my hopes for this
um pgg group and the in the um journey
that the council has been on is that it
becomes a
touchstone for other councils and that
the other councils will feel that they
can come and um speak with with
invercargill and look at the learnings
to be able to address their own problems
this could be an exemplar for new
zealand so i think we should take that
opportunity by actually diving a bit
deeper into
the question of what were the indicators
and could we have done something
differently early on it's going to be
hard because there are no right or wrong
answers but i think you guys are in a
unique position to have some really good
insights there
and and and richard field benefit just
to reinforce that when we first started
out on this this journey with the
thompson report and got a little bit
past that
i probably got
about a dozen telephone calls from
around the country from individual
counsellors
who are in councils that are not high
profile or dysfunctional
but have issues that are brewing very
similar to what we had
and they were quite interested to know
about how we were dealing with it
so you're quite right
through you mr chair um just one other
thing to consider along those lines is
just what role the letter from dia
actually played in in making
um forcing the council to actually
make some decisions around or to
acknowledge the situation
whether that is potentially because
that's outside what we did was outside
of any recommendation in the local
government act it was a unique step that
we took
and uh we took it for both invercargill
and tauranga councils and saw some quite
a different response so it would be
interesting to consider as part of your
learnings what role if any the
department should play in calling out
what it is seeing
and and that was part of the discussion
i had with the
with the local future local government
review panel some of their members was
you know in the future going forward
would it be the place of piece of
legislation with a government department
to then
flag issues with local councils and how
does that sit with democracy
or do we go to something like an
independent commissioner type role that
might have some effort in that area
that's separated away from government i
mean there's a whole raft of issues i
guess
so it was it was interesting that you
raised that as well
i think they
mr chair
issue of
teaching other councils how to behave is
i don't know i feel shaky about that i
mean even today
um
we had councillor soper taking one point
of view saying no this is not a
fast and you've got the mayor saying
this survey is as fast
and
so and
i think it would be presumptuous of us
to think we can
go out into the great world and and tell
people how they should behave
well let me reflect on that because i
don't think that's what richard was
saying
um there's nobody around this table i
don't think and anywhere else in the
local government reform area that's
suggesting that that individual elected
members should not have a voice
but it's how you express that voice and
whether you personalize the the comments
that you make to the extent where the
council becomes dysfunctional and i
guess that's part of our learning curve
that
and if you went into yesterday's meeting
as an example
the one about the museum if we'd had
that a year ago i guess we would have
blood on the table
and the media would have been would have
been all over it
and there'd be massive headlines and yet
we had quite a controversial meeting
yesterday and it took a long time and
there was some impassioned speeches and
you looked to the two media sources this
morning and there's no reporting because
it wasn't seen as inflammatory
um
and
we did business in a sensible way so i
guess that's what
one of the learnings that we should have
from this and others should learn from
it as well
um there is still a place for an
outspoken collective member
but it's how you go about doing that's
the way
can i just comment there there's a very
big difference between what richard said
about the possibility of
the report being a bit of an exemplar
for other councils
there's a big difference between that
and the
concept of telling other councils what
to do
the fact that there's a report that
shows how this council reacted to a
certain situation that might assist
other councils in the way they were who
deal with a similar situation is very
different from from trying to tell other
councils what to do or or suggesting
that
every councillor around the table has
got to
have only one view yeah
i agree
did you want to say something sir
was there any other comment about the
framework that jane and bruce are going
to use for which is appendix a
for the legacy report
oh just
a question has any thought being given
to whether the report would be a
majority report or a unanimous report
well i think
in good faith it would have to be a
majority report
would be my view i mean
um you just heard tim's view on some of
this
um tim has sir tim has been um
opposed to the thompson report all the
way through
in more recent times to his credit um
the dialogue has been sensible by my
view
and i hate to be critiquing that but um
so he still has the right to say um
i don't agree i don't agree with the
outcome so i think a majority would be
helpful trying to trying to extrude a
unanimous one
doesn't work because we've had that
before where we we had a unanimous
support for the original thompson report
and then
within a day or two it all fell apart
let's see some hands up richard
oh no i was going to just um
comment on the fact that yeah this i
think the key the key difference um that
invercargill has faced is it's it's
been able to um
take these steps without requiring any
sort of special legislation or
government intervention or anything like
that and so but um councillor slopes
spoke to that uh well that was the
intention it's this is this is looking
as an exemplar
um it's local government helping local
government rather than central
government telling others what to do
yeah thank you for that
jeff did you have some further comment
on that
no no it's good
i think somewhere
nobody if i can just say sure i think
there's a really important point that
jeff raises which is that actually the
intention must be that this report is
public so it's going to have to be you
know clearly received by
uh by council and and and made public
that's why
you would see the wisdom of sharing with
you essentially a draft if you can for
the in in april
uh so that there is a chance for
credible thought and thinking
before you then move into it but i i
look i would agree with jeff i think
jeff's intention is that it needs to be
accepted on a majority basis
yeah
the problem we're going to have with all
this is that
it's
very easy to
take a
simplistic view of what's happened and
i may seem oversensitive but my view of
the thompson report is that
we've got a problem
and the mares to blame
and i just don't think that's the true
story i think there's a
big narrative and that is
that amir is put in a difficult position
because
you are meant to represent an
independent voice
and
i think
i shouldn't be punished for that or used
as an example for that
and right the way through the thompson
report it goes over and over again
i know nobody you try and take a bit of
responsibility for it but
you don't come under scrutiny by half
compared with
what the mayor is being true
i'll be i wonder if hang on
i will respond to that before i give
leslie and lindsay an opportunity to
bring before that
um what i would say in response to that
your worship is that
you are not the only one that was
subject to criticism in the thompson
report
and my reading was that i got as much as
you if not more
um and claire also had some as well
um it's not about it's not about the
criticism it's about where you go on the
path after the criticism and i think one
of the issues that will should come out
of the invercargill report
is what happens when you have an elected
member um
and a keep key role like amir
um that is odds with the rest of the
council and and i think that's a
that will be part of our learning as
well because again under the
local government act our hands are tired
about how you resolve that
um
and i'm sure counselor podge over here
with here would have something to say
about that
so i just fought it i think leslie had a
hand up first
oh you're on mute lizzie
sorry thank you mr chair what you've
said has pretty much covered what i was
going to say about the
level of criticism in the original
report and i really don't think it's
it's helpful to
to rehash the whole issue of the
original court report we have moved on
um profoundly
through through a process that's been
good for council
and let's keep that forward momentum
going and await this report
and the and the influence this report
could have in assisting other councils
as a bit of an exemplar of how council
to deal with this in a positive way
without
without trying to
[Music]
once again relitigate the original
history and and who got criticized the
most or
who feels they will criticize them the
most et cetera it's just not helpful at
the stage where
um and the other things mr i'm very
sorry but i am going to have to depart
to a
district health board meeting at this
stage i do apologize
um it won't be a problem for the next
pgg meeting but
um i do feel obliged to to go to my
other elected position at this stage
sure
thanks everyone yeah thanks for your
input
i'll just respond before i come to you
lindsay in relation to what leslie had
to say
i think it's important that when we
go forward in our reports that we go to
the community that we don't rehash the
issues that were brought up this is more
about how we've dealt with them
and whether the processes we used are a
sense of learning for other councils as
well because when i think back
and i think about what got us the
original thompson report or the letter
from the dia we if i'm honest we had
some issues around the performance of
the mayor on a personal level we had a
deputy mayor and myself that was um
doing a lot of damage in the background
with the media which was unhinging some
of my colleagues and there were
relationship issues between between the
mayor and the chief executive and
between the deputy and streaming theater
i can't think of much in much examples
that would be much worse than that if i
really think about it
um so
it's not the issues that the way we've
come forward for that that should be the
focus and the focus for other people
watching this
so uh lindsay you had your hand up
oh look thanks uh i just wanted to
encourage you back to the agenda and to
not allow interventions including or
especially from his worship that
attempting to debate what the report
might have in and what its focus might
be rather than getting a sign off
as to its content in the path forward
the time to do
that is when you've got the draft report
in front of a council workshop not today
and thanks that feedback
but it's been my learned experience that
if you try and close down that debate it
comes back later on
and i understand what you're saying one
of the issues i had for for both jane
and for bruce was the issue
of the draft
do we need a draft report to be
considered because the draft by nature
gives you a full warning of what's
coming but it also gives you a bit of a
benefit to tink around the edges and and
i'm wondering given your experience
bruce and this is not furthering up to
you
why we need that opportunity to while we
just don't have a refined report from
you and jane that gets put on the table
and we decide what we do with it from
there
so um look i probably would take your
advice i mean i must confess navi my
viewers we should
uh and that's probably because an
independent reporter
should have a draft we should have the
draft because there is that in terms of
natural justice
i am going to be dealing with in a
report people's individual views okay
um and and it does affect the people on
this room plus plus those that are
so in that sense from a natural justice
perspective it's i think it probably is
important
that there is a chance to check that
actually
what we are reporting has been said to
us is indeed what the person that said
it thought it was
um so that's just plain natural justice
so arguably that would be the case i do
hear your point i think actually if
if i let richard say something rich will
probably say well here's a test
of of us from a government's perspective
which is actually
we are going to get we are going to get
a report you know independent in terms
of january doing the work
um can we deal with it appropriately
through normal channels
uh to then be able to move to a decision
on it so um
look i i would argue better for it to be
seen and draft by the council as a whole
and the way that we have in the past so
that we can clear it
so i'm just going to tease out something
for you
um
i assume that presentation of the draft
report would be in public excluded yes
my view my view i mean look my view
would be that we do it by way of
workshop sure um and it would be a
public excluded workshop um because
of you know i'm sure we can work out the
the
appropriate parts of lagoyama but in
essence it is actually personal
views being expressed and ones which um
affect individuals we need to
first of all have their chance to have
that discussion go forward before it
definitely needs to be received and
and uh debated in public okay
and i'm just going to deflect over to
clear now just to get a
staff perspective on that given your
experience in this industry
on the option of having a draft report
with some workshop to deal with it
before we actually formally table it and
going forward given that
when we have these sorts of discussions
one of the issues that we have is we've
got an on one of them
probably
some very noisy counselors around the
table who tend to say a lot and others
sit silent and so um
just just wanna not allow that to
overtake the process as well
in this situation i would defer to the
wishes of the report author
because it would be usual for the
process of it getting to the table and
getting accepted by the table would be
uh based on the report author's
preference okay okay i see
i'll take the
clear i'll take this on advice and just
check that jane and i can defer but i
think at this stage the the preference
for us is that we
we
give councillors the chance to to
provide us with comment the only
question might be how we do that if you
don't want to have a set piece of a
workshop it still raises questions about
how do we how do we get that natural
justice check on the report as a whole
i will canvass the views around the
table on that yeah we've got people on
zoom yeah sorry i'll come to them in a
minute
anybody else want to contribute to that
yeah jane i'll see you there just before
i go to you jane i i just
my thinking around the and not having
the draft was not that we shouldn't have
a draft breeze
i guess it was more around um
the time framing of putting some into
this and i'm not being careless about
that but
taking away the scaffolding i think is
important because it gives
as you know i'm not standing at the next
selection but it gives
the public an opportunity through some
areas of pressure be it rate reviews be
it annual plan be it
the election period to see whether we've
actually learned what we say we've
learned
and are standing up and acting in a more
professional behaviour
and i think if we stretch this out too
far
we encroach into that area so i mean i'm
more than happy to have a workshop but i
would like to think it to be sooner than
later
because i think there's some interest
from councils and what what will come
out of this and i think the media would
also be interested as well
mr chia i
i do have to express my concerns about
the scaffolding being removed too early
i do think that the biggest challenge is
embedding their behaviours
and i think that while the debate can
take place in a more
orderly manner now
there is still a matter of whether
counsellors are looking forward or
harking back to the past
and i think it's really important that
the council recognises that its
opportunities are ahead of it
working with a very different
organization
to that which it had 18 months ago
and to continue to
highlight failures rather than to look
forward at the
potential successes
uh
and and i think
would be detrimental to staff well-being
would be detrimental to public
confidence in the council
and i think that it's the scaffolding as
you refer to it
that has
just supported counsellors to keep that
future focus
so long as it's not seen as
avoiding
the issue or avoiding debate i mean
as i said i take a very simple
view of
this and
you mr chairman are responsible for some
of the
difficulties we've had
and
i and still having them um
just the loss of my pa for example
so we should
i'll just call that short look we're
relitigating stuff that we've been over
over and over again that's not what
today's meeting's about
and i will call back to the agenda as
he has suggested in the past
you have mechanisms available to you to
talk about your pa um mr women
yeah
look i i just think for natural justice
and for accuracy then the counselors
should have access to a draft report and
otherwise you'll open up for criticism
of the report as its final release
that's fine
yeah nigel
through youtube just reiterating clears
points and supporting them when you take
the scaffolding down and from my
experience it's
relatively important you take it down
piece by piece as opposed to all um the
end result can be quite catastrophic so
i would support the fact that we just uh
moved through that process
like any good scaffolder would take it
down piece by piece as we need to yep
okay uh for jane and fabrice i guess
you've got a pretty good steer there
yeah can i just check one thing i'll be
from perspective
are you wanting a short time between the
draft and when it hits the council table
i mean at the moment it's it's i think i
think we're sort of in the in the
monthly routine of pgg which is april
for a workshop it gets table but
are you asking for a compression well my
personal view is i think a compression
of that would be helpful as opposed to
doing in that time frame
because again if i was outside
council and i had an interest in council
i'd want to know that um
that members around this table and and a
significant amount of them are standing
again can perform in a professional way
um and that have not been
propped up by scaffolding all the way
through to the election i think there's
there's some degree of wanting to know
that
post the end of this work
that counsels around this table
including his worship and we've seen
some examples today of
him going back to issues
um can um
work in a way that would be expected at
the right pace
but i only go back to those issues
because
they haven't been resolved in my view
and well
your worship i don't want to relitigate
that
but you you you were part of the
unanimous vote to accept the thompson
report thompson report we've worked
through
um you've had any amount of opportunity
to talk about issues around cell phones
i.t
itn
and um
pa support and i'm not going to
re-litigate that
um
it's the view of most of your colleagues
and certainly on the advice from
from the chief executive that the level
of support that you have in the
pa area is suitable
and so if you want to make that an
election issue that you're more than
welcome to do that but for this purpose
going forward we're just going back to
square one if we keep relitigating that
so jane any other issues you have on
look i i think they've been covered the
one jeff picked up the one i was going
to add um errors in fact are really
important
and this has been an 18-month process so
that's
another good reason for having a
workshop
and also
just to remind the
group that this report tells a story
which is a lot more than just
the thompson review
it
covers a whole lot of other stuff so
that was all i wanted to add thank you
yes and just as a final reflection for
both you and bruce i think it's an
interesting process that we
feel in some ways that we've achieved
what we set out to achieve where in fact
we haven't
you can see by his worship's comments
today
that he is still back very much in the
early stages of this process
relitigating issues
and i could do and claire could probably
do the exactly same thing but we have to
move on
so
my final reflection on that
jane you have the uh
the wider issues on the project update
report to discuss now
uh yes there's only a couple there
um i think if we go back to number six
future reporting against outcomes you'll
see we've added a couple at the end
now this this table i feel is integral
to going forward
we don't spend a lot of time on it but
again when we heart back to the
beginning
we said it was really important to
measure what we're doing
and
this is an important table and i
wouldn't like to see it disappearing
however having said that there's uh
it could probably go to
risk and assurance when this
group
finishes its work so i don't know if
anybody wants to discuss anything on
it but it's something that i think
council should
retain
um even when this project wanes down
so i'll have some comments for you there
jane yeah and for bruce as well
um
it seems to me that we have some
unresolved issues around professional
development
governance
media training uh
tirio
see hunger mary
um
i think we're getting close enough to
the election now that some councils will
not be committed to those sessions
because they're not mandatory
um going forward um there's at least
three or four people that are not
standing at the next election so one of
the issues for
for the group going forward is i mean
i've had
years and years of tihangamari in
governance training
through the government sector why would
i come to these sort of sessions again i
asked myself
would i come to be supportive of the
process
as an ex-training manager i can tell you
that brings people into an environment
that are there for the wrong reasons
and so i i expressed yesterday at the
cheers meeting that i thought some of
these developmental issues that we still
got in professional development should
be targeted post
the next election for incoming people
but some of my colleagues felt that we
should keep the process going now so
just flagging that for you i guess
um and it's open for discussion about
where we go with on that the other issue
is the issue of the supporting the mere
uh work stream group so i'll come to
that as a separate exercise
uh open up the discussion for where we
go to on the professional development
side of things and where there are
opposing views
so it's um jeff here yeah jim well i i'd
still see for the pgg three roles and
that's the legacy report
um
professional development
not so much pre-triangle but i think
that the planning should start
later this year so that the
professional development on the new
council is arriving
plus the existing councillors starts in
the new year not
six months later after that's the
training
and i think the other one is the
councillor induction
program i i just don't think the
from the when we were back at the
workshops that we hasn't really been
developed or we haven't been
exposed to it at pgg
but i would have thought that
a conversation at least with councillors
in terms of the recent three
including the two maori representatives
about what they would found worked and
what didn't in terms of the induction so
that a
good induction program started right
away after the triannual for the new
council's is it quite three critical
roles i think left for pgg
so i'll open that discussion of the
professional development outcomes up for
other
to input if you wish
oh i see your hand up on zoom somewhere
richard yes thank you
that would be me i'm sorry just speaking
to um jeff's point about um the
induction program and the framework
and um this is probably a wider um topic
for the pgg to think about but um we've
got to think about the future role of
the project governance group and what
that might look like i mean we were set
up for a very specific role what we're
talking about now is actually moving
into something that's quite different
and perhaps there is a place
for some sort of oversight group in the
future if that's what the council allows
but i just think we need to
make sure that we're clear on what the
governance group's
role is in terms of finishing off this
project before we get into other things
that said totally support jeff's um
observation that um
uh planning should be underway in the
council for
training programs and for induction
because that's going to be critical
yeah thanks that important um and and
that's been my view as well that i see
that this group has a this group has a
finite legacy
um and i see the issue of induction and
professional development going way
beyond that and it should be business as
usual and i think they were both uh
parts that originated out of the
thompson report which ones i think the
responsibility pgg to make sure they
land somewhere outside of pgg yep
i agree good point yeah yep i've got
that
mr chair i wonder if that's an
opportunity to say that
alongside the draft report by bruce and
jane
there should be a review of the two
thompson reports and a confirmation or
identification of
all of the pieces of work
so that you can be satisfied that you've
done the lot or this is where the
outstanding remains yeah that's good
that's good advice yeah i've got that
thank you
did you get that bruce and jane yep yes
thank you
and the last issue for me on your report
jane was the issue of the supporting the
mayor group which was initially
supporting the mayor and chief executive
group
and i just don't see where this group
goes and i'm going to ask councillor
scott shortly to give some input into
that
it seems that we've made some links with
the mayor on a more informal basis
and if that's to maintain to be
maintained that's fine but this group
just seems to be stuck in the mud with
no progress forward on a formal basis
because in my view from what i've
observed
the issues are still the relitigation of
the
lack of support for the mayor and that
we just keep going back over that in
that group and so that group from my
knowledge hasn't met for quite some time
and it doesn't have any tangible
outcomes sitting alongside it at the
moment
so um i'm happy to
give the floor to you councillor scott
and give us an update on where you think
this should be you you
end up the coal face thank you cheer um
i guess there's two issues one is the
formality of the group which was set up
which which council labor chaired um
council and myself and council lewis so
the formality hasn't we haven't quite
got there in the sense of the continuing
on as you've outlined
um knobby
but the informal process just put in
recently from my perspective and council
lewis who can speak to it himself um
just a big thank you first and foremost
to to liz and her team and to michael
for his support
and
whilst it was acceptably extremely
informal the meeting we had with the
mere and the subsequent follow-up
from my perception
and the mayor can speak for himself
quite clearly but
from a demeanor and
a process it seems to be certainly have
worked
and been helpful
i've checked and informally back with
liz and with michael very informally and
briefly around the processes and it
seems to be a really good process
obviously one of the issues that fell
out of where the mirror was at
was the ability of
one around the ea or pa
slash and the hard copy of material
that was being provided up to that point
but there's been more emphasis going
forward thank you michael liz for around
that and i think his worship has
appreciated that um from my perspective
around council meetings and formal
meetings and his worship seems to be
and don't take this as an offence your
worship but more engaged and through
process
so that's been a really positive in my
opinion
um we have a very informal process um
and council lewis can speak in a moment
but very happy to continue on the
informal process to support
the mayor where we can both around the
meeting structure and the social
structure should he require it so
um
when we left the meeting we thought we
we agreed
informally that we would have a catch up
every month in general terms so that's
just about where we are now
um so very happy to do that again but
maybe council lewis you might like to
give your impression of the meeting and
where we are
just before we get to that night because
i'm going to ask graham and and ask your
stewardship as well so this really sits
outside the framework of what we're
dealing with in the working and working
together framework doesn't it's
something it's evolved but the fact that
perhaps uh as a result counselor but
perhaps not being having the opportunity
and being off site more so than in yeah
so it's rolled into an employable
process just because of our
of the situation we're currently in so
that would be a fair comment so if if we
were as pg to close down that work
stream and do no further action on it
your group and your interface with his
worship could continue on
i can always keep it yourself but yeah
obviously
um very happy to continue on but yeah
graham
thank you chair i would not have put my
hand up and if unless i was prepared to
persevere with help for his worship
where he needed it
after the meeting that council skelton i
had with his worship
i felt that we had achieved something
his worship seemed to be quite happy and
grateful for the things we'd set in
motion for the uh the time frame during
the day times or in the week that his
worship would have access to pa and
perhaps extra
coaching so to speak uh preparation for
meetings
and his worship was very graceful and
certain and thanked us
subsequently i was led to believe but i
wasn't at the
cheers meeting of course that
his worship was not too happy about it
so i'm quite interested to hear what his
worship has got to say about that
because i thought we'd sit and place
some processes which were going to help
greatly
his worship and and accounts from
january for the the demeanor that we
would have around the council and we
deal with some of the problems that have
been raised obviously and thompson
report et cetera et cetera
um which his mission has alluded to
today perhaps
so
cheer i'd quite i was very happy with
the way the meeting went very happy to
keep my hand up to help his worship
where we wanted and to be involved with
our little sub group
um so i'm quite interested to know what
his worship has to feel about it sure
because without his input and positivity
it's a waste of time sure
oh i've got a private life also and i'd
quite like to to make sure his worship
is happy we're on the right check to
help him
if he feels he needs help help
i'll give him the opportunity shortly to
do to tell you that that's really all
right just as a reflection on what was
raised at the chairs group
the chairs group um the feedback we got
from the mayor was not a reflection on
your input it was more a re-litigation
back onto the
on the issues of uh
wanting extended hours for the pa and
and other issues so that that was
that was my take on that and that sort
of
studied the water a little bit about
what we were trying to achieve with him
so
the analogy towards scaffolding has been
made today and i actually feel it's a
wee bit like ice skating on the fringe
of a pond the ice is quite firm but when
you start to skate out in the middle of
it it gets thinner and the more people
that are in the middle of the pond are
more likely to be
compromised by very icy water yeah
yeah maybe scaffolding's not the right
phrase to be using your worship would
you should be a scaffolding hand but
scaffolding is very important and
there's a concrete contractor for 12
years
i did a lot of scaffolding work
and
the
if
if you take it away
before the concrete set
you'll have a
tragedy on your hands and i had that in
australia where
the boss took the scaffolding down
and the roof collapsed and everyone got
killed except me
so i've learned salutary lessons and
i've learned a lesson from this
exercise too
and that is
that
um
you worship is probably the first time
in a long time i've heard you agree with
the chief executive
who
a few moments ago suggested that we
shouldn't take the scaffolding away too
early um so that was really positive but
i guess what your colleagues were asking
for here was
how you felt about their input in an
informal way as opposed to a formal way
the meeting they've originally had with
you and whether you'd like that to
continue on as we lead up to the next
election
well the jury's still out as far as i'm
concerned because
of the results i'm looking at
rather than
um
and and they have it taught me that
because it
i had to look at what my operation was
and
as a mayor
and it was
i thought if i can get one
victory or one success story out of it
it would be
the issue of the pa
because you said
i only needed 12 hours a week from a va
and
um not 40 hours like everyone else has
and
it taught me the value of
staff support you just can't seem to get
anything done
so your worship i i i've got to move
this generation along otherwise we'll be
here forever in a day because we're
really re-litigating
what we worked over many many times
about your support and i guess i'd be
interested to hear from your two
colleagues again
what their responses to what you've just
said because
i guess
and they can correct me if i've got this
wrong this informal support group was
not there to
to add weight to your claims for
extra pa hours or or to have a new cell
phone or
laptop training or whatever else that's
right it was there to i guess support
you in a in an emotional way i guess or
um so that
you could work through the period that
we have up to the next election
um so
concerning for me i guess as a chair of
this group that you say that the jury's
out on
your perspective on on the efforts that
your two of your colleagues have put in
and so i'll give them the right to
respond to that gram
if you would like to leave that thank
you chair
i don't expect to be presented with a
time sheet
for a pa
and then the need for it
but we discussed at the our little
informal meeting i say informal because
it was documented and recorded
um we discussed that if the need was
there
we could probably discuss with the
governance team to provide that extra
help
the initial help
that we
arranged
and i used the word loosely um
what was discussed was to make sure
there was a time frame of his worship to
have the pa in the mornings to present
to go over agendas go over any other
issues that they could be discussed
whether or not
one needs 12 hours or 40 hours we didn't
discuss at length but it was indicated
possibly that 12 hours would be enough
initially to go over any problems but
the problems if they would
identify god's worship were to be
or suggested he could report back to us
perhaps his first instance
to discuss with that
we still kept him formally
but i haven't heard any response back
from his worship since then so i really
can't see
how i can progress unless i find out
more details about his immediate needs
and
i probably will leave it there um
scaffolding i've got illusions of
scaffolding scaffolding hand to one
stage there's one gentleman turned up in
the field and he started to swing the
pole and i suggested he didn't swing
that pole because he would have hit the
power lines right beside it so there's
always a bright spark in the in the in
the group and i don't consider myself a
bright spark but i am concerned
about his worship
continued
aspects of
discussions about not having
support when we are offering it
but we need some
proper documentation
so we can comply with some of the wishes
i think
i'm here to help
if
if my help is still wanted
thanks
nigel
thank you
i can only eco uh councilman lewis's um
concept of what the meeting was about
and i thought we put in some really good
structures through and learning more
which was really important for us as
councillors a little bit more about the
time frames that his worship had and the
need and it was about need obviously
and we put in some really good i believe
some really good stepping stones for his
worship and the crew
around getting around time frames and
around content and around meeting
structure and material for meetings so
we left in a really positive mood uh
regarding that i have spoken through his
worship a couple of times and how it's
going
and
every indication to me in general terms
was apart from the access to a
full-time pa ea
every everything else was in good shape
in general terms so i'm a little bit
surprised this morning by um we're
really re-litigating that particular
point
but if his worship is feeling
comfortable and doesn't want uh the
support in an informal way then that's
fine we're not offended by that at all
we just go on our way but the offer is
still there you worship because we think
it's really important
you're an integral part of this team and
i talk about the team of 13 so
we are there to assist in any shape or
form but we're not there to relitigate
and spend time on those issues that um
have been clearly identified and again
um through process that we were given
and we went through all those processes
through that meeting and time frame so
if that's changed then that's fine we
accept that and we move on um so i'm
really keen to get some definite answer
today because that's
how
um
has indicated we're all busy people
and we can devote our time to other
things if need be so
whether it's formal or informal we just
need a real clear direction this morning
if we can within the next two minutes
otherwise the jury will be out and it'll
stay out
a chair i wonder if
i could intervene and make a suggestion
certainly
but i think we can give way being pg can
actually give that direction um it's
quite
challenging
to get that level of commitment from his
worship
especially in the context of the meeting
like today so just a brief recap my
recollection is that the original work
stream outcomes for this working group
were signed off at council level
including the resource in question
that has come up again today and i'm
suggesting let's not re-litigate that
i think when
um the person who's the subject of the
offer of support is equivocating or
uncertain
about their needs
it's still incumbent on the organization
[Music]
to consider whether notwithstanding all
of those things it puts support in place
and and my advice
would be that the pgg does mandate or
does ask the informal
group
to maintain its presence and be
available
to support the mayor's general
well-being should he request it i think
we do anything else
we
run the risk
of not being responsive to the situation
that we're facing so my suggestion in
short is that we note that the original
work stream outcomes have been met
and that we pcg asks the informal group
to maintain a presence
in the organisation in support of his
worship the mayor should he
uh
require it
yeah thanks and for i will put that to
group in a minute lindsey
i guess one of the things i
keen to clarify on this and i think
you've helped do that is that um
it was interesting his worship used the
words um i want a victory
and the victory is the pa issue because
if i'm brutally honest i think as we go
to the election
his worship will throw up the lack of
apa lack of i.t training the lack of a
cell phone and so on
for reasons why he doesn't perform at a
level that you would normally expect of
amir
and that's a horrible question to have
to deal with but it's it's there for us
and the sooner we
resolve the
issue of this work stream group and put
it to bed in my view
and then offer alternative support as
you've suggested the sooner we we step
away from that debate and it just it has
a life of its own but we don't get
enrolled in it because it will come back
to us again
as a group
and so i don't want to be sitting at
this table six months from now in the
lead-up to election justifying why the
mayor has 12 hours as opposed to 40
years we're way past that
so um
i think that was good advice that i did
but i will open up to the rest of the
group to
because the issue could be coming back
in your report bruce and jane
the suggestion as claire has put that
this
the future of this group could be
indicated in your report should now
lapse
as not completing all its original tasks
but it's got as far as it can get so
there's this work stream group that's
not perfect and hasn't been for some
time
and that and your recommendation could
then be that the
colleagues here who are still engaged in
an informal way around the mayor's
well-being
um continue
being mindful that we wouldn't expect of
the groups for them to relitigate the
things that go beyond the well-being
which are more
more the physical things that around the
office
potentially i don't know
but i will open it up for discussion
around the table
i guess
graeme and nigel that sits well with you
right
right just so you checked through
lindsay's comments around the
clarification of
support in the sense of at the mayor's
request or from that informal group
being proactive and for example saying
we'll catch up every month but as
opposed to
just at the mayor's request could you
clarify that for me what your thoughts
were uh before he does that um
lindsey and i have discussed this before
and i think it as he has alluded it's
incumbent upon an organization
if they have
a member of the organization struggling
a little bit to provide support you
don't ask you don't wait for somebody
struggling to ask for help so and i'm
not suggesting this in a negative way
but if you have somebody that had mental
health issues for a mistake don't expect
a person that's not thinking clearly to
come to you and say i need some help if
you can see it you you have a moral
obligation
and so that's what what he's implying i
think
is it am i correct in that lindsey
all right thanks chair and nigel yeah i
don't think this is something you can
script um i think it's a balance uh
nigel between
availability and responsiveness and
having your antenna turned in
you know on a weekly basis if not
slightly more frequently as to when you
might need to intervene
uh but you can't write a job description
for that or at least i couldn't so it
does
rely on
um
intuition and you know just
the the humanness i guess that goes with
relationships
thank you
and graham
i'm slightly confused
in my profession
in the health system
afterwards a scaffolding hand
i have learnt to recognize problems
but how do we deal with a problem that
somebody perhaps doesn't unders doesn't
appreciate that there may be a problem
it's almost patronizing to go up to
somebody and say i think you have a
problem
but we have some reports on things like
that to which have identified various
problems around the council and we've
been litigating those we've been dealing
with those problems and i thought i was
hoping that we've got far enough down
down the track
to be
um quite happy
with our results over over the last wee
while
and with the dia the external advisors
etc and it's been i think it's been
fantastic at progress
but this this um
i hate the term elephant in the room
situation as it keeps rising up
the request for 40 hours of pa
and perhaps we shouldn't litigate it
right now and discuss a great lamps now
but can we justify the 40 hours we have
we have suggested for us the system has
suggested 12 hours of pa work with the
addition of extra hours where it is
needed
it hasn't been restricted to that 10-12
hours
as far as i understand at our meeting we
discussed with his worship that if he
needed more perhaps just to discuss it
with us and we we will look into extra
pa
help prn as necessary
help i hesitate to see why somebody
should sit in an office for 40 hours a
pa sit there in the office waiting for
work
that's not in
the economics of that just don't stack
up for me
when they could be doing useful work
around the council and other aspects of
it but if it's needed it's needed we
have to quantify and qualify that those
sort of hours are are needed it's not an
examination on his worship it's just a
fact of life
if i had a staff
that
if i was short of staff in my
former profession i would
increase the staff levels
um but i would i want to make sure they
were actually gainfully employed
and the need was there
i'm not here to criticize this worship
i'm here to try and help his worship and
i think that has to be taken in the
right
attitude tim
that i've volunteered to help you and if
you need help please let us know it is
informal situation
we don't have control over the whole
governance structure but we can perhaps
recommend it if we're not informed of
the hours that you need for pa and that
seems to be one of the major sticking
points
please let us know
i respect you so much and over the years
i have when i've first met you
well before i was involved with council
i respected you all those years
and i still do i want to help you i
don't want you to suffer
i'm probably going off the track better
but i think that my message is getting
through i respect his worship very much
and if i can help him i certainly will
yeah thanks thanks graeme i'll just
really briefly clarify for you some of
the issues that you said um at the
recent chairs meeting we've had this
issue about the pa again
and so one of the issues i asked you
worship was you've got 12 hours but if
you needed extra hours claire's more
than happy to have that on an informal
basis
i said then what do you need the extra
work for
and i've got two responses
one is
all other mayors have got 40 hours i
said well that's not a need
that's just being like everybody else
what do you need the extra hours for
that person to actually do i didn't get
a response to that
and the second response i got was i'd
like her to be in the office when i come
in unannounced
i said that's fine but what's she gonna
do when you come and unannounce
that she's not doing there and i didn't
get a response to that either so very
much around other mayors have 40 hours
therefore i should have 40 hours and so
it we've lifted that because we just
can't afford to keep relitigating
so i mean i appreciate the support that
you're both giving and i hope that
informal stuff continues because it is
okay to sign up to somebody say are you
okay
um doesn't need to be correct critiquing
them but i think
giving claire's stare for bruce and jane
that could be something that comes out
of
the report that you bring forward that
this group needs the formal side of this
group need needs to lapse now
is achieved as much as it can do
as claire said that we've got other
issues to consider as well about the
professional development other things so
your report can cover that that would be
great
jane anything else you want to write
just one final thing um norbi page 15
item seven
there's a lot of discussion about what's
left for the
the um
this group to do
um
you know the draft work plan doesn't
cover the sort of standing items which
are the budget the risk and the project
outcomes
these key items were the sort of
strategic
bits of it
so for april and may
what we have discussed
is
rather than discussing the outcome of
the march review
um
we would have a workshop
ahead of the handover legacy report or a
meeting can we just be clear about what
it is
you wish us to do going forward with
regard to
a workshop or a meeting or you've talked
a bit about
scaffolding coming away i wish i hadn't
used that term now
yeah and there has been good discussion
on what's still left to do yeah so in
april
um
the strategic matter would be the legacy
report sure
i would have thought is that right bruce
are we on the right track
uh well i think i think if i can um yeah
i think in short it's actually what is
what does the pgdg need to do in april
clearly the big issue is going to have
to be legacy report of course but
whether it's anything else there's
another question
that's right yeah
and then we finalize it
in may is that right yeah that's the aim
at the moment and with some question
from mobby about
and and
note that it's finalized the handover
legacy report so as we've discussed
everything we've been doing
would go somewhere it wouldn't just
stop
so just a bit of clarity run that from
the the group itself uh
i'll be able to be good
and i'll open that up shortly and as
i've said previously i some compression
of that would be helpful
and one of the rationales as as as
counsellor
as grammar said um
we've made some significant progress
through the last 18 months
council performs by my view much better
than it used to and and we've all had
roles to plan that
i don't want to get our legacy report
caught up in the election area as we
lead up to the next election because
i'll put i'll put money on that the
mayor will not agree to the legacy
report the general outcomes there'll be
some dissension there
and i don't want that to become a
political footballer at the time that we
release it through the media we will
need to carefully strategize how we do
that allowing for his worship to be able
to be an opposing view
the lesson for learning was when we
unanimously agreed to the thompson
report and two days later
we got rules cited by a media
from media fiasco so i don't want to
repeat of that if we can avoid it
so
helping with that time frame bruce would
be good i think
i didn't catch that
mr chair
oh i'll just quickly repeat it i just
said that
um
i would like us to get the legacy report
through its draft process and out into
the media and away to the dia
before we get too close to the elections
that we'll need to have some comm
strategy around that because we may have
descending voices around the table
including your own about the outcome
of the report given that it touches on
issues of leadership
and so
i don't want that to be sitting up there
too close to the election where it
becomes a political football i think as
grammar said it takes away
from the gains that we've made it's not
perfect where we are
but it's certainly vastly improved on
where we were at 18 months ago
and so i don't want to lose that in the
election hearing because you can sit
around this council table now and see
potential mayoral candidates lining up
they are taking positions of points of
difference
and i don't want that report to be a
casualty of that sort of approach as we
lead into the election
so really the question
is is actually rather than the process
when does it need to be out by
so the the point that i think jane and i
were making start
is that we have just pinned it to the
trajectory of pgg meetings which would
be the legacy report would be available
uh through final clearance of the pgg in
may for presumably the main council
meeting
i think i think if i can put words in
your mouth you're saying too late
priests is that right that's my view
yeah um and you've suggested it to
counter that that we could have some
workshops to deal with the draft that
don't have to be tied into this time
frame no it doesn't i do
i don't know how
easy it is
natural justice and actually yes we need
to do something
yeah so i'm open to really your guidance
and lead well i'd i'd like us to be to
be able to put that final report out
earlier than may that's my personal view
um and that doesn't make it april
because they're just four weeks apart
but we can bring that back a little bit
i think that would be helpful
we've got some other contentious issues
coming up around may too around rate
strikes and yeah the annual plan and
stuff like that and i just don't want to
get caught up in the debate that might
be in that arena i think in fairness to
um might i say jane who does the heavy
lifting of this i have to be very
careful on this one and give all credit
to jane she wasn't doing we had lifting
when she pulled the boat down we will
need that period through april to
put theater because actually um i like
all the points that have been made today
but but it actually does have a weird
weight to it which we need to be
aware of the timing between getting the
draft actually done in denver's adoption
is much more flexible yeah than probably
the time needed essentially the month
that's needed to get that report well
that's what i was trying to set your
guidance on because i i don't think
there needs to be much time between a
draft workshop and the release but it's
if you recall if you called in some of
those hard
terrifying days when we started this
project we turned them around in 24
hours yeah
but what i'm hearing from you is the
issue of getting the draft report right
yes
that's most critical for us mr chair i
would just point out that the draft
annual plan is proposed to be adopted on
the 22nd of march
so three weeks
and april has quite a bit of disruption
because of easter and anzac days so
i just urge you to think about those
school holidays is in there for two
weeks of course yeah basically you get
to 14 april and then
for a lot of people there'll be no
business until after anzac okay thanks
i'll leave that with you with your lead
that you you allow jane and i to talk
with claire about actually how we fit
this and in
a critical message as early as possible
uh um and particularly shortening the
time between um uh review of the draft
and its publication sure that'd be great
just leave in your hand
thanks eric have we got a cora mr chair
yes
i'm not sure about that can you help me
that clear i believe so
um
i will double check but i believe so
half a number of members we've lost
uh nigel and
leslie but uh both of the eas are
members
as as as myself i'm satisfied that you'd
have yep
yep thanks yes we do have a quorum clear
i'm sorry you're not actually a formal
meeting and a formal committee under the
governance structure in any event thank
you
do you have some concerns about that
your worship
no if we're not allowed to um
meeting to continue with the
forum
well
as as the chief executive advised uh
we're not bound by those those types of
rules and we've got a significant number
of members here
that are um the two eas myself
are you in it bruce
i think you are claire graham
tim
so any amount of number um
so for me that's that's
where i end anything else you want to
add to that jane
no no thank you
any other general business around the
table
well mr chair
i just like to round it off by
saying i appreciate the help that graham
others have made to
nigel to
get
through this
consultation type of
process and
i don't like to surround
destructive or
but it's just that
um
i've felt that
it's
always just had to be made and i'm still
not
i think if we went to any other
council for city council anyway around
new zealand
you wouldn't find that 12-hour
limitations
was necessary so
i'm not going to go back over the
12-hour litigation
we've discussed that numerous times
today and it's been discussed to death
previously
and what i will reflect is that um
i think you have colleagues that are
prepared to support you on on a personal
level i appreciate that that you've now
said that you you appreciate that so
i'll certainly let councillor scalp know
as well
and it would be my expectation that and
then at the next meeting we will close
down the work stream group as having run
its course
and
i i still am resistant to the
suggestion by you which continues on
that the lack of support be it from
claire's area or from
support from your colleagues is the
reason why we have some degree of
leadership issues with the nurse council
and i think
you are blessed
with the time that you've been in as
amir and this council and other councils
and your best that the framework that we
sit within
uh allows you to continue to perform at
the level you're at
and so
i'll just leave that in there
and if we have no other issues i'll
recommend that we close the meeting
and thank you for those that have zoomed
in
[Music]
thank you mr chair
thank you
and we're done
downstairs